so Martin you have been hitting this
message since what year 2009 is when I
wrote my first book the lights in the
tunnel what level of preparedness do you
think that
that we have either in the U.S or
elsewhere for what AI will mean in terms
of the workforce education government
democracy media yeah I mean I think it's
a pretty minimal level of preparedness
and you know that's not surprising I
mean if you look at history
the big changes adaptations happen when
we really get into a crisis right I mean
uh we had the Great Depression and a
Great Depression produced Social
Security and unemployment insurance all
of those things would have been
unimaginable before that crisis so I've
I've always kind of felt that
you know the kind of things that you've
been talking about as well like a
universal basic income or or ideas that
I think need to be considered seriously
in order to adapt to this for the future
but it's it's just
an extraordinarily radical idea right in
terms of the political context
especially in the U.S and I've always
felt that there's almost no possibility
of something like that happening
until there's a fairly dire crisis right
so that probably will be what it takes
my hope is that by having at least a
conversation about this and making
people aware of it and maybe doing some
experiments with Ubi to gather the
necessary data information that we need
to really craft a program that if and
when we do get into that crisis then
maybe we can adapt pretty quickly but
you know just just in terms of the
politics in the United States which are
just getting worse and worse and it's
impossible to do even the smallest thing
let alone something
something so radical like like a UPI
that uh you know I think it will
probably take a crisis you know before
before we really make those kinds of
changes and how how do you see a crisis
like that uh shaping up and incidentally
I agree with your estimation in many
ways back in the 70s when Nixon was
looking at basic income equivalent
um they actually did large-scale trials
in communities around the country saying
oh let's see how it goes so uh I uh
heart and back to that because it seems
like we're light years away from that
now in the U.S where if someone were to
look at it and be like oh let's just try
this in in places I think we should be
running trials all over the country to
your point but how do you see this
crisis manifesting yeah I mean it's hard
to predict right I mean for example when
you wrote your book you talked about
um trucker revolts right the truckers
were gonna block the highways and stuff
like this and as I said now it looks
like it's more the the white collar
that's progressing faster right so so
we're gonna see the white collar workers
may be impacted first and actually
there's a hopeful note in that I think
isn't there because you know if it's
fast food workers and Walmart workers
then those people don't have a lot of
power you know but white collar worker
workers you know High income consultants
and attorneys and people like that I
mean that's
I mean that's more or less the backbone
of the the Democratic party really in
terms of the people that that you know
Drive the politics
um so I think there's some hopeful note
in that this might be a bit top-heavy in
terms of how it impacts and and actually
impacts some groups of people that
actually have more influence and power
over the political system than the other
groups of workers might and maybe that
will help to drive things a little
faster
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you